when we first started learning about
fractions or rational
numbers we learned about the idea of
putting things in lowest terms so if we
saw something like
3
6
we knew that 3 and 6 share a common
factor we know that the numerator well 3
is just 3 but that 6 could be written as
2 times 3 and say since they share a
common factor the 3 in this case we
could divide the numerator by 3 in the
denominator by 3
or we could say that this is just 3 over
3
and they would cancel out and in lowest
terms this fraction would be one half or
just to kind of hit the point home if we
had
8
over
8 over 24 once again we know that this
is the same thing as 8 over 3 times 8 or
this is the same thing as 1 over 3 times
eight over eight the eights cancel out
and we get this in lowest terms as one
third the same exact idea applies to
rational expressions these are rational
numbers rational expressions are
essentially the same thing but instead
of the numerator being an actual number
and the denominator being an actual
number they're expressions involving
variables so let me show you what i'm
talking about
let's say
i had let's say that i had
nine x
nine x plus three
over
over twelve x plus four
now this numerator up here we can factor
it we can factor out a three this is
equal to
three times three x
plus one that's what our numerator is
equal to
and our denominator we can factor out a
four this is the same thing as 4
times 3x
3x 12 divided by 4 is 3 12x over 4 is 3x
plus 4 divided by 4 is 1.
so here just like there the numerator
and the denominator have a common factor
in this case it's 3x plus 1. in this
case it's a rational it's a it's a
variable expression it's not an actual
number but we can do the exact same
thing
they cancel out so if we were to write
this rational expression in lowest terms
we could say that this is equal to
3
over
4
that's equal to 3 over 4. let's do
another one
let's do another one let's say that we
had
let's say that we had x squared let me
see a good one so let's say we had x
squared
x squared minus 9
over 5 x plus
15
over 5 x plus 15. so what is this going
to be equal to
what is this going to be equal to so the
numerator we can factor it's a
difference of squares we have x plus 3
times
x minus 3 and in the denominator we can
factor a 5 out this is 5 times x plus 3.
so once again a common factor in the
numerator and in the denominator we can
cancel them out but we touched on this a
couple of videos ago we have to be very
careful we can cancel them out we can
say that this is going to be equal to
x minus 3 over 5 but we have to exclude
the the values of x that would have made
this denominator equal to zero that
would have made the entire expression
undefined so we could write this as
being equal to x minus three over five
but
x cannot be equal to negative three
negative three would make this zero or
it would make this whole thing zero so
this
and this whole thing are equivalent this
is not equivalent to this right here
because this is defined at x is equal to
negative 3 while this isn't defined at x
is equal to negative 3. so to make them
the same i also have to add the the the
extra the extra condition that x cannot
equal negative 3. and so likewise over
here if this was a function if this was
let's say this was we wrote y
is equal to 9x plus 3 over 12x plus 4
and we wanted to graph it
when we simplify it the temptation is
well you know we factored out a 3x plus
1 in the numerator and the denominator
they cancel out the temptations say well
this is the same graph as y is equal to
the constant 3 4 which is just a
horizontal line at y is equal to 3 4.
but we have to add one condition we have
to eliminate we have to exclude the x
values that would have made this thing
right here equal to zero and that would
have been zero if x is equal to
negative one third if x is equal to
negative one third this or this
denominator would be equal to zero so
even over here we'd have to say x cannot
be equal to
negative one third that condition is
what really makes
is what really makes this
is what really makes that equal to that
that x cannot be equal to
negative one-third let's do a couple
more of these
and i'll do these in pink
let's say that i had
let's say that i had x squared
x squared
plus six x plus eight
over
over
x squared
plus 4x actually even better let me let
me do this a little bit x squared plus
6x
plus 5
over
over x squared
minus x
minus 2. so once again we want to factor
the numerator and denominator just like
we did with traditional numbers when we
first learned factoring when we first
learned about fractions and lowest terms
so if we factor the numerator what two
numbers when i multiply them equal 5 and
i add them equal six
well the numbers that pop into my head
are five and one so the numerator is x
plus five
times x minus one
and then our denominator two numbers
multiply negative two add adam negative
1
negative 2 and positive 1 pop out of my
head
negative oh this is a positive 1 right x
plus 5 times x plus 1 right 1 times 5 is
5. 5x plus 1x is 6x so here we have
negative
we have a a positive one and a negative
two so x
minus two times
x plus
one
times x plus one so we have a common
factor in the numerator and the
denominator these cancel out so you
could say that this is equal to
x plus 5 over x minus 2 but for them to
really be equal we have to add the
condition we have to add the condition
that x cannot be equal to negative 1. we
cannot
because if x is equal to negative 1 this
is undefined we have to add that
condition because this by itself is
defined at x is equal to negative 1. you
could put negative 1 here and you're
going to get a number but this is not
defined at x is equal to negative 1. so
we have to add this condition for
this
to truly be equal
to that